um
bob and you worry about that you're going to
spend your whole life without junina rains
the truth is that you're going to want to see me here
11 is that what's his name is
gabriel still tell you something this
boy is doing very well who knows he's not
mine  prince charming
bye bye gabriel 5 above i
always have to say that i never saw
gabriel playing the flame of work as he
should find it here
it's not for nothing
i
thinking about it for the second set alone
at night in the dark that was for me it's
always dark yeah  what things were
great the day you arrive now they can't
talk about my best friend anymore that's
what's going to happen in your life a lot of
things are going to change it
was a new boyfriend
they care